how are you coach I'm good well good to
be with you as well
so I don't there's many different ways
to start with you but I guess I'll start
first with your batting practice I saw I
know that that's not really breaking
news but I saw you get in there you hack
from both sides of the plate did you
leave the yard as a right handed did you
leave the yard I was at the wall twice I
was closed I needed I needed one more
session you know it's been quite a while
since I've had a little little BP
machine in an open field I think I think
we'll move around I couldn't I could
have gotten out of there so I had a
little warning track power going for me
the other day the wood bat threw me off
that that's that was a little different
but what a thrill man it was a lot of
fun to be able to get in there and but I
came back and got with the team
yesterday and and I told him a lot of
you know prayer and that I'm gonna stick
the football and stick with this spring
being a it was tough to walk away
beautiful weather down there and coach
it was very gracious and you know I had
a good bond with the team but it's just
what I got to do it this time no I make
sense they stick to what you know in
that regard you know you did lace when a
right field as a lefty I saw that you
pulled one you just pop one of the night
I saw that I checked that out yeah it's
been a while since I've been on the
other side of the plate but you know it
was fun was fun to get in there I've
never had the opportunity to do that so
I was kind of a bucket list thing and
you know I thought I thought they may
just put me like you know in the in the
cage you know where you were you hit but
no I didn't know he was gonna put me out
on the big boy field but it was a it was
a ton of fun and you know hope to do it
again one day a lot of fun that's great
come through so I'm just fresh back from
the combine I'm sitting next to Daniel
Jeremiah on the NFL Network broadcast
and a commercial break I told him that
I'm having Dabo Swinney on the show on
Tuesday what should i an't what do you
think I should ask and he's like as
we're watching the defensive line group
and we see five defensive linemen and as
we know you can only play
or but we see five from Clemson the
question is do you have any left
there do you have any defensive line
players left there in Clemson well we
got some guys but we got a lot of work
to do that's for sure but man that's
what that's what makes it so much fun
you know all of those guys that were at
the combine will freshmen one day too
and you know so they came in and did a
nice job and I think we got some guys
here that are ready and we got a few
sophomores and redshirt freshmen we've
got I think we got a I think we've got
two juniors in our D line we don't have
any seniors so we'll be young but
talented and and I'll tell you what
those guys that that are leaving they
they left a great you know imprint on
this program and a model for all those
guys to to strive for so just good
people great players but good people
about the right things great students
you know just excited about you know
their opportunity and yeah I know you
just got back from the combine because I
got my Rich Eisen six all week I love I
keep it all in one Oh in my office all
the time and you do a great job thanks
coach with all that stuff it's always
fun to to keep up well I put my golf
announcers voice on you know got to keep
it nice and low for all the valuators
there in the building it's pretty
intense you know and it's just uh it's
pretty it's it's a pretty intense
environment normally the receivers we
see that you send to the next level big
tall physical receivers you send in a
pretty special guy though to the combine
and Hunter Renfro promit able for him
what do you think he can do at the next
level the he's gonna he's gonna do all
the things he did at Clemson he'll do at
the next level but better just because
he's he's just he's just going to
continue to improve he's going to
continue to get stronger and he's still
a work in progress from that standpoint
you know he was he was weak as a noodle
when he came to Clemson and and now I
think he did seven reps 225 so he's
Hercules now and from where he came in
at and I'm just excited about
his opportunity he's really developed
into a great player and you know he may
not have some of the measurables but I
promise you he's six-four two-twenty on
the football field
and can fly he's as good a player as
I've ever coached ever and I don't know
how else to say it no great ones but all
positions included he is as good a
player as I've ever coached this guy is
the epitome of what makes the game of
football so much fun it's so special and
you know he'll be passed a million times
because that's what that's what people
do they overthink it and I can just tell
you somebody's going to get him and and
he's gonna be a great player no doubt
about it and just awesome in the locker
room and unbelievable teammate he's
almost like a coach on the note as far
as his mentality and mindset so I'm
excited for him and you know I got
another kid that didn't get invited
named trayvion Thompson who's gonna make
it as well he's we had two senior
receivers this year and you know
treyvion's just kind of like Geron brown
kind of like Adam Humphries who both
have had long great careers now in NFL
both were free agents
but treyvion kind of overshadowed by T
Higgins by hunter and by Mike Williams
and those guys and so but he I'm gonna
tell you what javion Thompson can play
and I knew you wouldn't get invited to
combine but he's a guy that that's gonna
make it in that league for sure he's got
all the tools and we just have you know
you can only play a few of them we got
and he played a lot that's a big place
for us had a couple great plays in the
nati so I think both of those guys will
will for sure make it but hunter is an
interesting guy cuz you know he looks
like he looks like the guy that you know
is the least likely gotta be an NFL
player if you lined him up in a room but
he's kind of like Clark Kent man take
them glasses off and he turns into
Superman and got plenty of film to back
it up against the best of the best in
this country so you
do you'll continue to the same thing at
the next level National Champion Clemson
head coach Dabo Swinney here on the Rich
Eisen show and then there's talk about
the very talented kid that you just won
the national championship with at
quarterback and Trevor Lawrence and the
conversation that happens so often with
bowl games for players miss skip their
bowl games to stay healthy for an
eventual drafting now there's even a
conversation that your kid shouldn't
take another snap that he's done enough
to be the first round draft choice two
drafts from now he was asked that last
night when in media and he he said he
pays that no mind I wonder what you
think of that talk coach I don't I don't
think of it you know but that's because
it's just such a waste of my time you
know that's the world we live in and you
know my thing is why play at all you
know I mean there's plenty of
opportunity hey man that's great we got
a we basically have a minor league now
and I think that's great
I think gives people opportunity if you
don't really value the college
experience or value the education and
all that comes with it hey you got
another opportunity down I think that's
correct you know you can go ahead and go
to work just like you know people do in
other sports whether it be basketball or
minor-league baseball or whatever but
I've never worried about stuff that I'd
have zero control over and rhetoric and
all that but anything that will get a
headline people will put out there but
you know Trevor's the epitome of what's
great about college football he loves
his experience and and he still got a
long way to go man he's got a lot of
work to do and he's eager to get his
education and continue to enjoy the
college experience that he's having but
you know I mean my job is to coach the
guys that that are here and and the guys
that value this and that's what I do
day in and day out and that's what I'm
passionate about it you know really
excited for Trevor and certainly his
future if he can continue to progress
and you know do the things that he did
this past year on the field
a couple more minutes left with Davos
wouldn't here on the Rich Eisen show I'm
wondering you know what you think of the
new in the NFL evaluation of a
quarterback being 510 and 1/8 and that
checks a box saying the calamari is Pro
ready what do you think of that new
fangled world in the NFL do you think
you and the college game has had any
influence on that oh I don't think
there's any question just like just like
the high school game has that influence
on the college game because you know the
that's your pool you know our pool comes
from high school players and NFL pool
comes from college players and you know
the game has changed a lot especially at
the high school level as high school
coaches have had so much competition for
for athletes you know with year-round
sports and all those things and you know
so I think that coaches over the last 10
15 years you know have changed things
it's become more of a spread game and
and those type of things as opposed to
just you know getting in the hind going
on right now everyone it's also are just
one option and you know kids keeping
kids engaged and and and wanting to play
and having some fun along the way so the
game has changed and that's where the
you know in the 707 and all that stuff
the development in the skill has been
amazing with quarterbacks and the
receivers and the blacks because of that
and definitely just chuckled up took a
college game and then now into the pro
game you know I can remember when I got
the job or when I was kind of
implementing our offense here what I
want to do is a better captain where you
can never win a championship for that
offense because it won't match up with
defense and all that mess and that's all
that's all that was a great theory but
you know that didn't hold water and it's
the same thing at the NFL level for
years and years and years you know
people say oh you know it's complicated
game
this stuff and you know you can't have
sugar quarterbacks and you know Matt and
certain styles of play won't marry up
and and now it's changed when you see
the accessory success of mahomes and
under fill' and Watson and and you know
those type of guys Baker going in and
these guys are are so prepared coming
out of college now and then you know the
NFL the teams that are winning have made
adjustments and they've added different
principles to the game that these guys
are familiar with because it's what
they've done all the way back to high
school and and it's things that are that
apply to any level of football and you
see it whether it be even be even Tom
Brady and and some of the things that
the Patriots do you know you even see it
in what they do offensively you know
obviously they're not gonna they're not
going to run Tom Brady and but this
fourth things an opponent even if you're
on the ball handling and things like
that I think that it puts a lot of
pressure on defenses and and caller is
exceptional I mean he is you know
again people overthink things and all
the analytics or whatever get involved
in measurables and and people miss out
on a bunch of great football players
because of it but I don't I don't know
that there's anywhere on the planet that
plays the game of football that calimary
does it fit in he throws the ball really
well he's accurate he's so explosive I
mean you hold your breath every time he
every time he drops back because if
you're just not perfect and he makes one
kind of miss and if you're playing any
type of man coverage you're in for a big
play and so I'm excited for him I think
he he'll be drafted high and I think
he'll do well at the next level for sure
last one for you coach we saw Christian
Wilkins on the NFL Network after he was
done with his workout he goes back to
his room and he ordered five different
orders of well five different order five
orders of check
wings I'm one did he pick that up from
the White House I don't know I don't
know you have to ask you but I was like
pretty good old me know I've gotta hug
you right now sounds good okay did you
did you have any of the hamburgers or
did you have any of the fast food when
you went to the White House
absolutely absolutely I had a I went
with the Wendy's single cheese and a
couple pieces of Domino's Pizza okay you
know it was it was a great trip awesome
I'm sure love in three times and I don't
remember what I had to eat the other two
times but I'll never forget I'll never
forget this one
did your nutritionist come up to you and
what was the conversation only I don't
that we didn't really give him any any
opportunity to to jump in I don't think
he was real happy but hey you know a
little indulgence every now coach thanks
for the time really appreciate it always
enjoy our chats you know it's been a
while since you wanted also this the
first time we've chatted so congrats on
that look forward to our next ones all
right I appreciate it thank you take
care be good you got stablish Winnie
Clemson head coach the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience